please be upstanding members to receive
the chairman the Chairman's chaplain and
the managing director please remain
standing for prayers evening everybody
look forward to welcoming you into Holy
Trinity tomorrow night for our cow
service and in this Advent season of
watching and waiting
that is pray loving and generous God we
are mindful in this season where we
watch and we wait
help us to watch our communities to see
the greatest needs and give us wisdom in
how to respond help us to look out for
one another as we do that work of our
community and gracious Lord in this
season of waiting and our culture that
is not very good at waiting
help us to be patient help us to enjoy
those moments of stillness where we can
marvel at that story of Immanuel God
with us the Lord in all the work and
activities of this evenings meeting we
pray that you would leaders and guide us
by your holy spirits and be glorified in
our midst our men
please be seated members
[Music]
a warm welcome to your members officers
and members of the public on this the
full council meeting of the 17th of
December 2019
I shall take item 1 on the agenda
apologies for absence chairman apologies
has been received in the office one
councillor sparing any other apologies
members no thank you
I shall take item two on the agenda the
minutes of the meeting held on the 22nd
of October 2008 19 do members approve
the minutes as a correct records of the
meeting councillor wooden chairman if I
can take you to item 196 page 5 the
bullet point there on the third line in
my reply on questions I inadvertently
got rather excited about the rich
heritage of the district in which we
live and instead of referring to a
thousand years of Ashington church I
went to unremarkable hundred years it
should of course be a thousand years but
the minutes are absolutely correct in
terms of what I said but I think that
correction is worth noting make Thank
You Council of all what and that
amendment will be noted in the minutes I
think he was keys just to correct the
record I think the record is correct you
through the rates to this meeting okay
thank you for that correction right I
shall take item three on the agenda
declarations of interest any
declarations of interest members there
are none
item for agenda announcements from the
chairman leader of our head of paid
service there are no member no
announcements from the leader er sorry
the head of paid service I would like to
remind members of my own Civic carol
service which is being held at 7 o'clock
tomorrow at the holy trinity church
there will be refreshments afterwards
and you're more than welcome to like to
see as many of you there as possible I'm
also now have got a Twitter account
there's a Chairman's Twitter handle at
RDC chairman I would look I look forward
to you're following me on the Twitter
all right I understand also that the
leader of the council would like to make
some announcers but before I asked him
do so can I remind members that
questions related to any of the
announcement announcement made under
this item of the agenda shall be raised
outside of the meeting no questions will
be allowed here tonight counts a step so
Thank You chairman I'm in the position
to announce the installation of electric
vehicle charging points paid for by a
grant from the Department of Transport
under the air quality work that we've
been undertaking jointly with Basile and
council the project is progressing well
and the next phase is due to be carried
out this week and we include eight
charging eight charges being installed
in the following locations back Lane
carpark Rochford one rapid and one fast
charger the approach carpark Raley with
two fast chargers market carpark Raley
one rapid r1 fast charger which you can
actually see just let's go out of the
door there Webster's way car park in
Raley two fast chargers
this will increase the number of charges
from two to ten a five-fold increase in
a further phase a rapid charger will be
installed in South End Road Hockley and
to rapid taxi charges at freight house
Rockford and subject to planning consent
bending ham Lane in ready the
installation of these Chargers charging
points is a positive step towards
encouraging the use of electric vehicles
and will make it easier for our
residents and visitors to the district
to offer to move to operate more
environmentally environmentally friendly
vehicles and this is a note there I
noticed that on a lot of Sat Navs now
they actually show where the electric
charge of points are or another matter
members may recall recall that in 2012
the council was a signatory to the Armed
Forces covenant which is a promise by
them by the nation to ensure that those
who have served or have served in the
Armed Forces and their families are
treated fairly I'm pleased to announce
that in response to a letter from the
Ministry of minister of housing and
homelessness and a parliamentary
secretary of state and the Minister of
Defence of people and veterans
councillor Leslie butcher has agreed to
fill the role of armed force covenant
champion for the council and I will be
arranging for this to be a formal
appointment at the annual Council in May
councillor butcher will work closely
with officers to develop a series of
actions and initiatives that to support
the principles of the Covenant finally
chairman
the Association the Southend local
councils authorities the Asmus for short
was investigating the potential for the
creation of South Essex investment fund
to deliver opportunities for growth in
South Essex Accela has common
consultants working on proposals and
arrangements are in hand for a briefing
for all members by the consultants early
in the new year if any member from from
all sides of the chamber would like more
information please feel free to contact
me after this meeting Thank You
councillor Steptoe I shall now take
agenda item five public questions and
member questions on a notice of which
there are none agenda item six business
from the last council meeting members
there are none agenda item 7 mm its of
the executive committee meetings held
between the period 9th of October 2019
and a third of December 2019 do you know
the minutes of these meetings members
agreed thank you agenda item 8 reports
from the executive and committees to
Council this is this will be item 8 is a
report of the review committee 2019 2020
treasury management mid-year review and
councillor Burton chairman the review
committee will reintroduce this report
Thank You councillor Burton Thank You
chairman um during the municipal year
the review committee receives three
reports on the council's treasury
management function this report is the
mid-year review and is fairly
self-explanatory if any members have any
questions I'm sure that no me Lucas will
endeavor to answer them and if not then
I moved that the contents of the report
be noted by for council
Thank you Thank You councillor Burton
couch councillor Newport counselor mrs.
Mason Thank You mr. chairman the review
committee asked for the original report
to be amended before presentation to
council but we appear to have the
original report as an appendix with a
summary including the required
amendments being presented to Council as
a report of the review committee without
it being seen or approved by the review
committee I'd like to ask some questions
on it anyway on item 1.2 I quote however
the practice in previous years of an
automatic carry forward of the capital
program underspend would be reviewed
this year ahead of the budget to ensure
that whatever is built into the capital
program can be delivered may I ask the
portfolio holder who will be undertaking
that review what criteria can be
delivered is being used is there a
specific time frame and not being
delivered now would indicate some issues
with project management however when
would this rubric be reported to the
review committee
I should last mrs. Lucas to respond to
that question
I directed the question to the portfolio
holder mr. chairman councillor smith i
you'd happy to answer that question
chairman there's quite a number of
facets to that question it would have
been ideal if we'd had a advance notice
so we'll undertake to provide a written
answer to that thank you thank you
countess myths counselor mrs. Mason yes
thank you for letting me come back on
that point I would have thought having a
report that hasn't been through a review
committee it's quite hard to actually
preempt what's going to be in it however
I have got another question if I may mr.
chairman which I will direct to the
a section 151 officer could she confirm
that the 95 day accounts and notice
accounts and not a fixed period and can
she explained why the higher 95 day
notice account is infested it's placed
with Santander at a lower rate than the
Lloyds 95 days notice account I'm
assuming they are notice accounts
supplementary to that in respect of the
365 day account again it's not clear
from either report whether it's fixed
notice a fixed term or notice and what
penalties are incurred should the
council need to withdraw before the end
of the 365 day period so could you
confirm that because we should be
looking at reducing risk Thank You mr.
chairman
Michigan point of order if you don't
mind please the questions that have been
asked a really quite complex and I think
it's unfair to expect answers to come on
on the evening I think it would be much
easier if councillor Mason could provide
it those questions in written format so
that we can ensure that she gets a
proper and full answer point of order
firstly its councillor mrs. Mason as you
probably remember it's something that
I'm quite touchy about as I happen to be
married for a very long time are very
proud of the fact these are not
difficult questions and had we had the
report at the review committee then we
could have looked at that then this
report it says at the top report of the
review committee this report has not
been seen by the review committee and
that is why these questions are being
asked in Abbott to know whether we've
got a notice at K on a fixed notice
account or a fixed term account I would
have thought was a fundamentally basic
financial question if it's not I'll
accept a written reply but I don't
intend to giving these questions in
writing because that would be a motion
which I have not done thank you
mrs. Lucas are you happy to come back on
that point
yeah I'm more than happy to and well
sorry and yeah I'm her son councillor
Smith them indicated due to this sort of
complexity of their questions and in
order to give a full and correct answer
that I would come back after the after
the meeting but I would just point to
the fact that the table which was
updated at the request of the review
committee does show the investment terms
and the noticed periods of the various
accounts so as council mrs. Mason
alluded to the 95 day in 365 day
accounts as their name sort of implies
require that amount of notice in order
to withdraw the monies but obviously
that's done in full view of our cash our
cash requirements so what we ensure we
have adequate liquidity that we won't
need the funds for the period in which
they invest it okay Kara mrs. Mason
you'll get a written response Thank You
council new pool a mr. chairman um could
I ask the portfolio holder which Bank is
behind the money market Deutsche Fund
and do they keep the assets in cash and
also what are the ratings mrs. Lucas
will on today sorry chairman we can only
undertake to provide written answers to
complex questions that require accuracy
and detail again mr. council Newport
you'll get a written response in that
was and that question any other
questions
okay I'm sorry count of some issues all
of us first the appendix to the report
the same assent to review
just just to clarify the the original
report is the appendix on the advice of
officers and member services in terms of
how the reports presented batts accounts
or the supplementary information was
incorporated into the covering report
which is essentially just to set out
what was taken to review committee and
their supplementary questions that were
asked as part of that committee meeting
so yes I'm it cares to mr. Holly Thank
You chairman I'm just coming back to to
the report again from the review
committee it was requested that the
actual ratings of the bank's were
included in the report and our criteria
for lending were also included in a
report by triple-a I a plus and so on
however it's not it's not in the report
which is the original board and it's not
a it's not in the office of report for
tonight and that was a specific request
of the review committee I yeah I don't
believe that wasn't minted but if it was
I apologize and we can certainly provide
that information and the ratings that we
adhere to it's part my treasury
management strategy us out to fork is
set out to fall Council and review
committee at the beginning of the year
and the report does confirm that we've
been compliant with our strategy
throughout the year so the information
has been presented to members already in
the public domain but appreciate that
wasn't sort of fully picked up in parts
they're supplementary report cancer
Stanley
please forgive me for not getting up
question is which bank is behind this to
the portfolio holder which Bank is
behind the body market crime and what
are their writings I think it's probably
slightly complex to explain and at this
meeting so I think it is better if I
incorporate that information into the
written reply it's given as part of the
other okay councillor Burton Thank You
chairman um just to say that I'm
surprised as chair of the review
committee I'm certainly not aware that
there was any questions raised about the
ratings of the bank and I certainly
didn't expect to see it in the report as
far as I'm concerned in German place it
was clearly in the recording of it
obviously it was clearly raised thank
you if it was and it was and the review
committee agreed that it should be
included then obviously I'll stand
corrected I'm not aware of that and I'm
looking at other members faces who also
look bewildered by that and secondly it
would be helpful I do think as members
of the review committee that sitting
here raising questions this evening
really could have raised some of these
questions at the time of the review
committee and I do think quite frankly
it's unreasonable to expect the section
1 5 1 officer in portfolio holdup to
answer questions on the sphere at the
moment when those that are asked the
questions were actually members the
review committee could have a state
that's on also mrs. Mason well I'm sad
to hear that said because some of the
questions were raised in the review
committee and what we actually asked for
was the original report to be amended
before presentation what we have is a
different report so we could not have
asked questions on that additional
report of the review committee because
it wasn't presented to the review
committee however I set the section 1 5
ones officers of written replies to the
questions raised as if she's unable to
answer them now but what I would ask is
that those responses are given to all
members of the council
as is customary with reports thank you
Thank You members I think this is he
discussed there far enough there are a
number of points been raised and a
written response to all members will
come forth from the one five one officer
there is one recommendation members on
page eight point two of the report that
a treasury management 2019-20 mid-year
report including additional information
requested by the committee within this
report be noted is that agreed members
thank you right we go on to agenda item
nine report on urgent urgent decisions
members there are none agenda item ten
report of the leader of the work of the
Executive Council Steptoe when our
report to the council to work at the
executive as since the last council
meeting
Thank You Jenna this is the third
ordinary council meeting of the 2019-20
was it for all year and I would like to
welcome all members since the meeting on
22nd to October the ecords executive has
met once during which considerations
included noting the quarter to 2019 20
financial management and performance
report along with the latest position on
the council's key performance indicators
point in a cross member working group to
provide a stakeholder input and feedback
to support the development of a car
parking strategy an action for the
district together with the approval of
the car park review member working group
items of reference and agree the work of
the working group will not commence
until after the general election kellton
12th of December
she's now passed notes in the context of
the program management office dashboard
and agreeing the removal of the homeless
project from the scope of the program
management office the updated items of
reference new workflow a new project
indication document were also agreed
other matters that the executive and I
have dealt with include adoption of the
tenancy strategy 2019 20 to 24 and
delegating authority to the assistant
director people and communities in
consultation with the portfolio holder
for community to make amendments to the
strategy in response to future
legislation changes changes at local
regional level and or government
guidance adoption of an enforcement
policy for people and community
directorate and matrix for determine
levels of civil penalties to be you
issued specific for specific housing
related offenses the green at the formal
response to essex county council
consultation on the changes the
developer's guide to in infrastructure
contributions be submitted within the
prescribed time period noting the
authority's authority monitoring report
2018-19
which will be published as part of the
council's evidence for back and base for
planning chairman as always i'm happy to
take any questions from members in
respect to the work of the executive and
i'll sure my executive colleagues will
only be too happy to compliment
contribute where appropriate
ma'am just take this opportunity to wish
everybody happy Christmas and a good New
Year Thank You council Steptoe are there
any questions and members for counts a
step to any questions must of course
relate only to the subjects within the
report counselor mr. Hoya thank you
thank you for just a couple of questions
when he's on the first body point about
the working group in relation to the car
parking stretch Ettore just a couple of
questions on the end there's a question
on the next bite as well could he could
the leader please let us know when they
expects the first meeting of that group
to meet and obviously 6th and state the
terms of reference sorry and also in
it's probably a general wider point on
that item but it relates to other items
as well that the only work would be
executive
obviously within the review committee
there is a working party looking at
the how the council could go carbon
neutral by 2030 that feeds into all
items I think within the council in
relation to these not specifically how
does how do you plan that working group
to feedback into the carbon neutral
working group on there on the from the
review committee it's quite a different
question I know it might not be thought
of yet because obviously you're you're
considering something you've you already
thought about electric charging not just
leave that there when I was getting
questions on that and I just wondered
how the executive is he's feeling about
how the feedback works and any feedback
both ways to that working party on the
review committee will work I believe
that the portfolio hold has already
attended one working party for the
review committee carbon 2030 well I just
wonder how the rest of it would work if
that's possible the second question was
really on the next point which is just
why is it why is the homeless project
being removed from the scope of the
program management office Thank You
Council Steptoe Thank You chairman um
I'm not sure the exact date of my head
I'll go to quickly look at the officer
and ask for coming
the German 23rd of January is that
meeting thank you
so 23rd of January with regards to
feeding into the carbon neutral working
group that is something that yes needs
to be considered at this particular
conjunction I don't think there is a
mechanism for it to happen but the
portfolio holder will take note of that
both portfolio holders will take note of
that and I'm sure that that will happen
during a period of time with regards to
the what was the UPS railcar it's called
the other question
thank German can I refer that question
to the portfolio hold it is possible
please
Thank You chairman so this is in
reflection of the fantastic work that's
been carried out by Louise and Moses
team understand a significant reduction
in the number of families in b and b
within the district you know it's over
that number dropped to zero and we've
also seen a reduction in the use of
temporary accommodation within the
district as a result of that it was
thought that the work that was being
carried out on the homelessness project
was no longer a gold project obviously
still remains very much and something
keeping up on Springs what the situation
doesn't get back to where it was before
but that's why it's been thought that
they should be taken out of the
dashboard for now Thank You councillor
Webb counts to Wilkinson Thank You
chairman and if I could just ask the
lead in relation to the the item
regarding the consultation from Essex
County Council on the contribution from
development companies regarding the
infrastructure is obviously something I
think we have interested resolve as we
know residents across the districts have
been calling for more infrastructure
whilst development increases I'm sure
there's gonna be more specifics to this
I'm not asking you to attend with them
all but I wonder if you could just
summarize what that looks like and what
our responses relation to that thank you
canter Steptoe chairman can I refer that
to the portfolio holder for planning
infrastructure placement counselor Ward
would you repeat that question please
councillor Wilkinson relation to I the
bullet points talking about the official
response from Essex County Council so it
reads that Essex County Council said
there's a consultation regarding the
changes that development companies will
have to provide towards infrastructure
my question is obviously as we're all
aware there's a huge amount of emotion
across districts of whilst the
infrastructure increases that we need so
whilst developments increase we need to
see the infrastructure and case with it
so this seems like a really good idea I
just wonder if you could summarize for
me what the consultation looks like what
the suggestions have been and what our
responses to that councillor Ward again
this sounds like a very complicated
answer that I'd have to give you on that
one
I'll have to come back to you on that
one and I'll come back to the council as
a whole in regards to how we're going to
view this current consultation obviously
we all recognize we need to have
infrastructure and we need the
developers to be able to deliver some of
that infrastructure but also there are
lots of issues with regard to viability
and that is something that we do have to
really examine we know the government is
looking at various ways in which it
wishes to how can I put it extract value
from the land and that is something that
is also going into the various
consultations that are going on but we
need to get a good idea of what is
coming back look not only from Essex but
from the government itself in how they
want to view we've got a new government
that's coming in and it's going to take
a new view
I would guess on how we're going to go
about providing infrastructure but it is
quite a complicated system all the way
around and we need to understand it
ourselves but our pressure is to get as
much infrastructure as we possibly can
and extract as much as we can from
developments Thank You councillor Ward
council snip tow chairman if I could
just add a little to that I met today
with the portfolio holder at Essex for
infrastructure and he is looking at
a number of things that are likely to be
coming forward from central government
they haven't come through yet the early
days yet I think there's only about four
days so far so there is bound to be a
number of things coming through a lot on
those initiatives over a period of time
Thank You mr. Chancellor Steptoe can
smoke way Thank You chairman my question
relates to there seems to be another
report these going towards the
evidence-base going into into the
process for the renewal of the local
plan from from memory we are close to a
point where another major report is due
to come out and public consultation
period is is there any possibility of an
update as to Wayne the public
consultation he's gonna gonna start for
for that next next period thank you
counter Steptoe chairman I think I'm
looking at the management director here
but I believe the consultation is quite
some way off of yet there's an awful lot
more work to do before it gets to that
point if I'm incorrect on that I'm sure
that management director will correct
thank you can Thank You counsel step two
kills the Hulk while he come back hmm
yes thank you chairman thank you for
allowing me to come back
yes SSA I remember from previous
meetings that there was a timetable
looked at is there is there any
particular reason in why this is seems
to be being delayed and and the
processes seems to be being dragged out
is there one particular thing or is it a
multitude of different issues that
causing delay council scepter chairman
can I refer to the aportfolio holder for
planning on that place councillor Ward
thank you very much in regards to the
delivery of our local plan where you're
sort we're looking at the evidence base
we are working through our Asylum which
is through the whole South Essex area
and that is a joint strategic plan where
a lot of the evidence is being gathered
by all the various groups we are come we
are actually bringing one of our
officers into this so it's a combination
of all the officers throughout South
Essex who are looking throughout the
whole area of what we need because the
requirement is for the whole of South
Essex and we need to get the evidence
base it helps us we got I think it was
somewhere in the region of about 900
thousand pounds from the government to
help towards getting this evidence
together so that evidence will
ultimately contribute to how we will be
looking at our local plan and going
forward so it's taking time yes I know
but it's about the resources we have
we've got some of the resources which
are were coming from this joint
strategic plan thank you Thank You
councillor Ward councillor Wilson Thank
You chairman m-class the leader is in
relation to the third bullet point and
it's the last sentence says the updated
terms of reference new workflow a new
project initiation document
we're also great could you tell me what
project the project initiation document
refers to a place council stepped Oh gem
and I'll have to refer to their
portfolio hold of the community on them
councillor Webb Thank You Jen and for
memory this is to do with the way that
were actually monitoring office
dashboard so these are the gold projects
within the council and as an executive
we wanted to make sure that we're aware
of those projects within the council how
they were performing so we could
actually hold officers to account around
that and for memory the project
initiation document is just a new way of
actually looking at information
and actually makes making sure that as
the executive we can assess it
information I don't believe it refer to
a specific project but of just the
overall documentation that helps Thank
You councillor Webb
rush I now take item 11 members motions
on notice of which we have two the first
motion has been opposed by counselor
mrs. Gooding mrs. Gooding would you like
to counselor mrs. bloom would you like
to summarize and speak on your motion
please Thank You mr. chair I'd like to
put forward to explore ways that
Rochford District Council and Essex
County Council can work together to
improve the cycle ways by connecting the
various parts of the cycle tracks in and
around Rockford district and in
particular using I'm will aim to create
a cycle way through from Rockford town
to honk well to make a safe route for
cyclists instead of haul road linking
the two new housing estates and the new
industrial area at the airport the
benefits of improving cycle routes will
include safer journeys avoiding busy
roads reducing carbon emissions by not
driving fitness benefits including
health improvements a reduction in use
of the NHS by engaging in an active
lifestyle while enjoying the outdoor
environment and improving well-being in
addition utilizing Iron Bowl aim will
also bring this ancient highway up to a
suitable standard to encourage lizard
pleasure use Thank You counsel could
encounter step toe Thank You chairman I
was very pleased when Gooden approached
me on this particular point it is
something that we really need to be
looking at and in particular Hall Road
house good
originally approached me and said what
can we do about putting a cycle track a
little hole road because it is quite a
dangerous road particularly night and
what have you so we sat and thought
about it and we thought well okay what
about I'm will Lane I will lane as
catherine has already said is an ancient
byway it is the original coaching rote
goes way back a haul road was actually
developed as the toll road and put in by
were laying out of action
now it's asked to make a bit of sense
when you look at it and you think well
that will connect Rockford and the haul
road new Hall Road estate through to
pork wall and the Christmas tree estate
there is a little spur that comes off of
line where Elaine comes down to haul
road which then just a hop skip and a
jump to actually take it into and
connect into the new industrial area and
of course Cherry Orchard Park there is a
possibility that may be coming forward
with some cycle ways within the park
which would then a link it right the way
through to ready so it doesn't actually
start to make a little bit of sense and
makes it a very safe environment for
those who's in the site cycle and
particularly younger people so I'm only
too willing to support this motion just
as a footnote I had a conversation today
with the portfolio holder for
infrastructure at betty's county
councillor councillor Bentley who is
very very keen on cycle ways and was
only too willing to support this so it
will need a little bit of work behind
the scenes to identifying what we
actually need to do how we need to take
it forward particularly with I'm all
right
maybe it's a possibility that we need to
look at its status because currently it
is actually technically a roadway the
vehicles produced but of course if
you're going to turn the cycle track it
would make more sense if that's easy
slightly downgraded to be able to
achieve that
there's a number of little bits of cycle
track in and around the Rockford area
along the Ashenden Road
again that would all start to link in so
it makes it feasibly possible for
somebody to actually cycle from Rockford
through to Riley without having to use
the road network and I would suggest
that's a far safer option than some of
the roads the narrowness of top of the
roads that we have so I'm in full
support of this motion Jim Thank You
Kansas depth Ocala eaves it you wish to
speak thank you Jeff it's a very
laudable project
thank you very much as the call I'm
actually very familiar with this
particular route because when I was
doing my apprenticeship I used to use
that all the time to go from hawk well
to Rockford I have was however not aware
that there was a spur that goes through
to haul road so it's not very clear
because obviously I'm line is one lane
and it doesn't give us an indication
here of a spur it was just a technical
point really to actually underline that
there is actually a spur that we could
develop within this project I think of
your comments counties counselor mr. hoi
Thank You chairman I shouldn't expect
I'm sort of in favor of motions like
this and I generally wouldn't have a
problem with it I'm just a little bit
confused why it's fair it's nice the
administration basically putting forward
a motion to themselves to act on I've
just got a few concerns one of which
councillor step two has mention about
line well line it is an ancient Highway
and I'm concerned about what you mean by
and develop or improve I think it words
whereas the improve wasn't it and I'm
wonder what you mean by improvements
I'll be talking while we trying to keep
the character of the line it needs now
or to improve into a site called
superhighway I'm not sure I'm a bit not
sure about that so that's one of my
concerns also I just wanna move on to
something probably a bit broader which
this relates to I think
when I was chair of the LHV and since
then and prior to then Essex County
Council has a policy of trying to
implement a cycle route from Southend to
chumford which incorporates significant
parts of this district in fact we're not
on the lhp there was at least a hundred
thousand pounds set aside for that
project we have four county councillors
who sit on this council or members of
the LH where we have five further
district councillors who sits on that
lhp as well and I would have thought
this would be the that would be the
place to take it forward or through
there certainly is some money there in
addition I would mention that for the
whole bridge development there's a
hundred thousand pounds of section 106
money for that very project available to
spend not for I'm Elaine I apologize for
that for the district members for their
area but for the for the whole of the
project so I'll make at least two
hundred thousand pounds I know when I
was on the HP was would cost quite a lot
to do the whole project but surely we
could him we could RC Essex to look at
our bit of it to at least get ourselves
linked up in line of that I would like
to propose an amendment to the motion
which would remove the the following
words in the first paragraph so the
first part he's fine it's quite a long
sentence it's just from the park places
in and around watch a district or just
like to remove and in particular using I
wall at well lay up until the point it
says hawk will leave the resting and
then from instead of full Road take
everything out else out so it just
finishes to make a safe route for
cyclists and then in the second
paragraph to remove the final paragraph
which then does everything that should
be been done through the HP there is
money available I know and I think we
could all support that how heart of
yield don't know if I have a seconder by
proposed emotion thank you okay
counselor mr. Hoyer just to be clear
then of your amendment if I can read
that read it back to you to explore ways
that wrote for District Council in Essex
County Council can work together to
improve cycle ways by connecting the
various parts of the cycle tracks in and
around Rochford district to make a safe
route for cyclists instead of whole line
linking okay yes it is okay I should try
and get near is that is that better
sorry counselor help mister hi where
were you sorry chairman you brighten it
just finishes at the for stop it after
cyclists then the rest of that paragraph
otherwise it snows then the last line
comes off as well yes yeah and then the
second paragraph is just the final
sentence from in addition because it
meant things to our site do you have a
second of for that amendment character
wilkinson chairman thank you and I do
wish to second this but I just like to
ask a question if I may when I first
read this I was really really pleased
because I'm a really keen cyclist and it
fits in with everything that I stand for
and everything which we've been trying
to do and I really prayed council misses
getting for bringing this to the to the
council and I'm totally totally in favor
of it I just wanted to clarify something
which is why I do want a second what's
council mr. Hoyer is saying is because
when I my second reaction to reading
this was it seemed to me and this may
just be my ignorance at the jogger for
the area that it was particularly around
the Rockford area and being a Rayleigh
counts residents etc obviously I'm
thinking about the Raley side so really
up that the way that council mr. Hoyer
has amended it in my view just takes
that ambiguity out and it makes it a
district-wide project which i think is
probably better
okay counsel Kenny oh did you wish to
speak on the amendment of course yes
first thing I'd like to say is again I
was also pleased to see this on the
paper so I would like to thank cancers
Gooding and constitu for bringing this
forward to Council I was also a little
bit concerned around the wording
specific - I'm well Lane and I was also
a little bit confused as to the word
explore my understanding is that there
has been exploration in this area before
for example Essex County Council in 2016
put forward their strategy in which
they're cycling strategy sorry in which
they propose that districts have
five-year plans from the back of that
I've therefore read a draft from Essex
highways for a Rochford cycle action
plan last year which suggested
potentially 30 routes for the districts
it also noted that 3 had high potential
for cycling mode switch ie there are
routes that already used that we may be
able to take cars off the road none of
those three were actually in I'm well
Lane so my question before the amendment
and this was put was why specifically I
am well Lane and the reason I wished to
speak even though that has been removed
is just to see if we can explore remove
the word explore and start actually
action in some of the exploration work
that's already been put forward rather
than starting again from scratch my
concern is there's been lots of work
done in this area already and I would
prefer us if possible to move some of
that forward rather than explore new
ways to do this Thank You councillor
Khalil members I shall take a vote on
the amendment it's been proposed and
seconded the council scepter
if I'm Casper come back with your
permission one one or two of the
questions that have been asked there the
the status of our lame it is actually a
by way now one of the discussions I had
with councilor Bentley this afternoon is
to whether I'm I don't like to use the
word downgrade because that's not really
what I mean but it's changing status to
say for example to a bride away which
would still allow Nabal cyclists walkers
and horse riders to be able to use the
route but it would stop from vehicles
being able to have access through
through the center part of the route
they'd still have either ain't because
there's a number of properties at either
end of the room the reason that we
brought forward arm well a in particular
was because we've got a particular
problem around the whole Road section of
haul road from where it comes from
Cherry Orchard up to the roundabout with
rection Road it is unlit and it's a vet
quite a narrow road it's a 40 mile an
hour speed limit and there's not a no
footpath really to speak of in sections
of it and so it was there to make a safe
route it is the reason that we put in
the word explorer is that we need to
collate all of the evidence that has
been done cancer Canal mentioned that
there's a one or two bits and pieces so
we need to explore all of those things
and collate them all together to find
out exactly what we need to do and it is
a first step I think it was councillor
who I mentioned that there was some
money over a toll bridge from 106
agreements I don't believe that that can
be used other than within that
particular area it's quite limited with
106 agreements as to where that money
can go so I'm in this particular case I
don't think he could actually be used
for something like I'm alright so it was
a first step within the process it
wouldn't be the end of it but we've got
to start somewhere and it was made a
sensible suggestion that we started
there and then look at all the other
possibilities as time go
bye there may be other suggestions that
other members will have as we start to
develop perhaps a strategy that's not
the right word but a way forward with
actually doing it and I'm Elaine is a
route that is very little used it's just
about accessible for people the surface
it's not particularly good and any my
discussions I've had today that there
would be some assistance in actually
bringing it up to a little bit more of a
usable standard but of course what we
don't want to do is to encourage
vehicles to actually start to use it be
counter to what we're doing so at this
stage I'm afraid I can't support the
amendment of the motion and I would
still still be happy with the original
motion Thank You council Steptoe any
other mem members wish to comment on the
amendment councillor canal if I may and
obviously it's councillor his amendment
and I would suggest we amend the
amendment so that the first line reads
to summarize the exploratory work
already done to find ways that watch a
district council etc etc etc I'm not
sure if I have said that's not possible
councilor canal if there's no other
comments or questions on the amendment
I'll take a vote on the amendment and
members clear as to what the amended
motion is yeah those in favor of the
amended motion please has put forward by
accounts to mr. hoy those against
any abstentions that unfortunately has
been lost right will now take a vote
then on the substantive motion which is
the original motion sorry my apologies
we shall now debate the original motion
anybody need questions in respect of the
original motion has put forward by
counter gooding counselor mr. hoy Thank
You Chet I'm not gonna say again can
either counselor step to accounts
including say whether or not they've
already spoken with the lhp regarding
this this was in the LHB and I should
mix Tilly's if it isn't can you please
advise us as a council that's not the
case and with regard to councillor
Bentley was here whether whether or not
it was in the LH peace did or not I
understand that at the moment there's a
zero budget for cycle routes within the
council budget so I'm not sure how that
would be funding from the end they can
tiptoe chairman first of all what
councilor who says lhb I assume you mean
in the lhp so it's what Essex is
thinking they just to clarify that I'm
talking about the right thing yes I was
I being member of the LHB for quite some
time I do recall that there was quite a
lot of discussions going back around
cycle tracks particularly and if I
remember correctly it was around Cherry
Orchard way and there was quite a yeah
there was quite a bit there and routes
coming out to the south end know at this
stage I won't say that there's any form
of budget within the lhp to specifically
do it but we wouldn't necessarily be
looking to the lhp to be able to to fund
it it's one of the possibilities but at
this stage it might not necessarily be
the work the route we want to go Thank
You council Steptoe council Wilson did
you wish to speak okay council Wilkinson
HM M if I may just ask councillor step
so that I understand what he's saying
that we need to start somewhere totally
agree and I do support what the
council's trying to do here could I just
ask to have it on record that what he
says is that this is not restricted to
those two particular rows and this
project will explore all opportunities
across its history for cycleways thank
you council Steptoe chairman yes I would
have wholeheartedly accept Thank You
Carol sir mrs. Mason Thank You mr.
chairman don't surprise you as this is
if I walk that I heartily endorse the
intention I will clarify the point that
carries Road arose there is a dogleg or
there was a dogleg from the green lane
through to the whole Road roughly where
the roundabout is where the black
barneys because I remember going down it
as a child on my bicycle so whether it's
still there I don't know but that's
beside the point
I am concerned that this is very
specific though it benefits my residents
I would like to see it benefitting the
whole of the district and the
understanding that it will the this will
look at the whole of Rockford district
then I would support it thank you care
to step - Thank You chairman yes the the
piece the spur that I refer to probably
not the right word if you're traveling a
long haul road from Cherry Orchard
towards Rockford just before you get to
the new roundabouts you can see where
the track it looks a bit like a farm
track at the moment I believe the status
of that is actually bridle way
and is in private ownership but it is
partly a bride away which is the bit on
I'm talking about I think that's the
same bit alright so differently there
that was the bit I was referring to that
brings it down and then picks up with
the cycle track that's partly in Hall
Road already there was another question
there I forgot what it was sorry to
clarify for the leader mr. chairman I
was just concerned that it would this
would be district wide and we would look
at the whole district not just at this
specific point thank you yes this is the
first step of being able to try and do
something right throughout the whole
district it's the reason that we say
within Rochford district okay Sean
struttin would like to speak I've got my
apologies counsel the hook way Thank You
chairman like many members that have
spoken on this matter this evening I do
support the the idea and the and the
concept behind the motion when one
question that I have is has there been
any sort of thought regard to budget and
cost in relation to this or or is that
not been considered as yet thank
chairman now that's part of what we need
to explore yes we need to look at all of
that and where funding is going to come
from whether it's from 106 agreements
were from future developments there's a
number of sources there's cycling
funding for cyclists specifically
there's all sorts of particular sources
but yes we need to be able to understand
what it's going to cost this is the
first step yep Thank You council Steptoe
no other questions members I shall take
a vote
oh sorry mr. mr. Hawley thank you very
much late to become but it's just one
phrase small point it was on the section
106 for whole bridge maybe mr. scottson
or or mr. Houghton could confirm this
now or later but the section 106 money's
a whole bridge was
not for specific projects it was for the
concept of a cycle route linking for
that linking of Junction n and South in
perhaps within the whole bridge area
he'll be that section of it but it was
certainly for the the concept not
perhaps I'm very happy to meet with the
leader outside of this meeting maybe to
discuss how options within whole bridge
could contribute to these cycle ways as
well and how and perhaps the use of that
money Thank You councillor mister hoi I
there's no other members indicating I
shall now take a vote on the notice on
motion as detailed in item 11 proposed
by councillor Gooding and seconded by
Councillor Steptoe those in favor
those against any abstentions that
members has been passed thank you I
shall now all go on to item 11 again
this is his second notice on motion as
proposed by mr. mrs. Joe McPherson mrs.
McPherson would you like to explain your
ideas well have you seen these have you
seen this which are then research and
one of these happen to come through very
late at night but this isn't a new idea
a lot of counsel so I shall now read the
motion what should this be counsel to
work the basics County Council to
identify third geez that are suitable
for eco friendly latest wildflower
areas and also to identify suitable
areas for tree planting thank you
Thank You councillor Macpherson do you
have a second counselor mrs. Gooding yes
I'd like to second that Thank You
chairman thanks you can say gooding
counts the mr. Howie Thank You chairman
again another motion which is a very
good one
um just a if you can sir one courser one
service will reach I think they put to
rest by um counselor mrs. Macpherson
which is around the native are you
referring to ninety physics I hope
you're I'm sure you are referring to
native Essex peaches because that is one
of my concerns again I just wonder I
mean I've asked mr. Houghton before
about grass verges whether we can just
leave them clearly the best way to let
to let wildlife flourish is to leave
them not to plant to leave and that that
was one of the concerns I've had whether
or not this motion is in relation to
planting specifically or just leaving
the the verges uncut and I know
I believe their team at Watford has
tried to do that as much as possible mr.
Hutton can correct me if they haven't
but I'm sure I've had conversations
where they try and fit around our
contract around what we can leave and
what we need to cut what we don't which
is the best possible thing to do with
rod - tree planting or show me a favor I
think I think most members probably
aware that we have 4% recover in this
district we have less tree cover than
the City of London so I think we do need
to plant more trees and again we use the
word plant which I'm try not to do
because again the best way to encourage
tree growth is not to cut not to destroy
in the first place just to let them grow
naturally and you get you get the native
Essex trees or UK trees rather than
rogue ones getting in there from
planting so on the face of it I don't
really have a problem with the motion
it was just I wanted clarification
around that whether or not we're talking
about planting or just leaving uncut
which i think could work well with the
contract with Essex and maybe cost us
less money and also about the plans
converges in the only concern I've got
there is perhaps where it you're close
to Road waste and how the routes would
affect roadways and how much it would
cost us in Council on the Verge's to
upkeep the trees if we're with with
other councils for cost reasons are
cutting them down which I really don't
want to see happen mrs. Macpherson
questions that's why doing the research
some of the pollinate the plants that
are native Essex plants actually
encourage wildlife and improve the
ecosystem attract being set
it's been proven to work Thank You
counselor mrs. Mason risk let's get that
one all right I think I'm a little
concerned that we're linking to things
that quite different although on the
face of it they are similar we've got
the verges and cats and we've got
planting trees and they are
fundamentally different on the 25th of
November I asked the assistant director
would he advise what are tree planting
program is and what plans if any there
are to increase it his immediate
response was basically that the
additional trees are something being
considered by the carbon neutral 2030
working group and he would anticipate
recommendations to full council that in
the new year the carbon neutral 2030
working group reports the review
committee and includes the two movers of
this motion yet now we have a motion
that seems to be premature in all
respects on either trying to
second-guess or jump the recommendations
of the carbon neutral 2030 working group
and circumvent the review committee and
I am concerned from that perspective
neither does it make any potential
reference to the potential risk of
introducing non s6 native plants which I
think councillor Hawaii has mentioned
and there's also the risk from de
sidious trees blocking highway drainage
and creating potential flooding so this
motion is moving in the right direction
but this subject needs to be properly
investigated and in my view especially
bearing in mind what councillor hai has
said about feeding us of such problems
in projects into the carbon neutral 2030
working group the leader has indicated
that this process has yet to be
determined that this should be referred
to the carbon neutral 2030 work
group to take further thank you Tesla
mrs. McPherson this is about exploring
and working with Essex County Council to
look at an option here that has been
cruising taken up by our councils I
guess we could wait but to start
exploring it I don't see a problem at
all our climate is important to us thank
you mrs. McPherson yes
councilor meal yeah thank you miss Joan
um i essex as an ambitious plan to
150,000 trees so we need to move on this
define where we want to put them and I
think it's probably a little bit more
urgent than it sounds because there's a
big project going there's also a
national one to try and Link these
woodlands a wildlife can move up and
down the country and farmers have been
asked if they wish to turn some of their
land over for that very purpose so this
is actually quite a project and if we
start to look at this sensibly and get
this underway no matter who has the
report to really to seriously look at
this and say look what the funding is
and what the sources are the materials
that we can put in and there's certainly
a national project for this Thank You
councillor okay councillor step two
Thank You chairman just picking up a
little couple of points yes we will have
to take into account where trees are
planted particularly where there are
trains but bear in mind a lot of our
rural roads and don't have that sort of
infrastructure within them certainly out
where I am
they don't exist the other thing of
course is that we will need to take into
account and monitor what is actually
browning the verges if they're left well
because there are certain plants and
I've often said that in my particular
village one market ickle award
I've actually got more horses and I got
voters
and of course there are certain plants
like red rag work and those sort of
things which are dangerous to those
sorts of animals so that does need to be
monitored so you can't just leave it to
do its own thing you've got to have a
certain amount of control or management
shall we say to make sure that those
sorts of things aren't popping up where
we least least need them and I just
refer to the portfolio level environment
it'll make sure I'm right
I think you've said to me the other day
that we've got something in the region
of four million trees that we are
responsible for as a council Council
Williams thank you no I don't think it
was four million trees it's 400 to 500
thank you Thank You councillor stepped
oak right counselor mr. Hoyt if someone
could provide that for me please so this
apparently stemmed from discussions
within the working party on the review
committee the working party hasn't yet
reported to the review committee and is
unlikely to before the end of the year I
April can the Chairman's Revenue
Committee confirm whether or not this
item is still been looked at in the
review committee or whether it is now
outside the roof or you can see how
we'll who's exploring the opportunities
to me it would seem best that the the
working party that was already looking
at the issues should look at the issues
otherwise there's not gonna be another
working party cuz you need to look to
work with Essex County Council or is it
going to be the lead I've talking to his
County Council or the portfolio holder
talking to the Essex County Council
about it it's not going to be the how
all of us is it as watcher district
count so I just wanted how that process
is intended to work because he doesn't
say so in the motion and if they're
armed the review committee couldn't
comment whether or not that is still the
review committee is still looking at
this item and will report back on it as
well
all that has now been removed from their
remit I'd like to know thank you how's
the burden would you like to come on on
they're all I would say that is it
certainly hasn't been removed and but I
don't think it would have been this
particular motion wouldn't have been
specific to that working group of the
review committee however this and some
other issues I do think there needs to
be some clarification how
do you work in groups interact and and
feed back to one another and I think
that's something I will need to discuss
with with some of the members here this
evening but as far as I'm concerned it
hasn't been removed for them the review
committee but it wasn't specific to the
review committee but I agree I do think
that it probably would have formed part
of it I think it seems a bit pointless
to be discussing it specifically now if
this motion is passed and it is assigned
to to another working group or somebody
else so I think it's clear from the
discussions deceived in that there needs
to be some direction with regards to how
these are taken forward Thank You
councillor burn encounter Steptoe Thank
You chairman this is also connected to a
motion that would came forward at Essex
County Council because of the amount of
tree planting that they're doing and
being honest we want to get our fair
share of any trees that they're going to
be handing out from whatever bed freight
and of course yes there's been a lot of
discussions around the grass verges and
of course now is the time to do it
because come the spring you don't want
to have have you all cut and then expect
it to grow now it's the time to do it in
terms of come the spring and the the
growth that would appear start the next
year okay thank you cancer Steptoe
accounts no Stanley Thank You chairman
forgive me for getting up as
horticulturalists will know that grass
is the main evil to all plants as it
starves plants to grow its root system
will grab everything it possibly can so
to put plants in a grassed area would be
fatal to those plants just to let you
know also that I have been in contact
with a SCADA Council on this very
subject of trees and whether certain
trees can be planted they would have to
be the variety of DeWolf trees and not
major mature trees as they
bro so in that respect they already
understand that the wolf trees and there
are special plant rose tree growers that
will actually do this in respect of
going needs a grass verges they won't
actually what trees have done in the
past is to fruit up take up the
footpaths and and block drains so these
trees that are being brought out from
what I understand won't affect footpaths
in the way of route disturbance to the
footpaths and also to drains so just to
inform those other council members of
what issues can't care so either mine
too and obviously about grass if you
don't cut it it will just be gross and
it'll seed itself again and again so if
you want to put plants in you have to
take the grass away and leave the Graham
rough and not fertilize
thank you thank you can sustain Lee
Kemp's a water thank you no I was just
interested in in if there's a kind of a
time sensitivity to getting the trees
from Essex because I mean that just came
up especially if we're having to wait
for a report to go to review is there a
case that we actually need to try and
find out where we are so that we can
actually get these trees from Essex or
is there a case that if we wait too long
we won't get them that's just a straight
question I just like to know the answer
please counsel step toe
the Chairman the toilets imitates a
sensitivity was more around the grass
verges because they're obviously dying
back at this particular stage and
picking up on councillor Stanley's point
there about grass certainly out where I
live in Barling what-have-you where the
grass voters are cut in a lot of places
there the wildflowers do do quite well
what we used to call cowslips and
various other bits and pieces and
there's one piece of road where the
loopings are going loopy for one of a
better phrase with regards to the trees
now I'm not sure how time-sensitive that
is within excellence County Council but
that's something we would need to
discuss with them hence the reason it
says to work with us is character
council missus counselor mrs. McPherson
I think we're a little bit mixing them
up here yes we do mention identify
perches that are suitable for eco
friendly native wild flower areas and
also to identify suitable suitable areas
for tree planting prickly our parks with
other open spaces not necessary
Thank You counsel Stanley Thank You
chairman
Lowe pins are not a natural plant to
Great Britain just to reform you with
that care slips are and care slips will
grow in open field more or less rather
than grass verges that we've got on
outside our front doors where we've got
where he is predominantly leaf grass the
grass that referred to in ditches and
what have you that virtually is not it
is a grass but it's called a rye grass
which has come off the fields and
naturally the seeds have been set it's
not horticultural grass grass Thank You
counsel Stanley
councillor Williams Thank You chairman
um I think we're getting ahead of
ourselves here the motion is to look at
what and where we can plant these trees
and wild flowers being allowed to grow I
fully support this being the portfolio
out of the environment and I just like
to thank counselor McPherson thoughts
and I think it's something we should put
forward thank you thank you
Counsell Williams I shall have one more
question is from counselor mr. Hawley
the Casa proceeding would appreciate
this I think we can myself and counselor
mrs. Macpherson will be well aware of
problems that could be caused by
ambiguity of wording within motions I
don't want to naturally put this myself
I don't know if cows let me see the most
fearsome would like to is just to
perhaps I'd I now understand you're not
talking about grass verges to the trees
whereas before I think I interpreted
just talk about grass verges and given
what happened in standards I think I'm
happy if I'll be happier if it was
amended just to identify and other areas
owned by the cows from such as part land
etc I don't know if you're happy to do
an amendment like that or not just so
after their problems with amendments or
emotion which can be interpreted in
different ways that's all thank you
yes the mrs. McPherson
always referring to but then I would
like to couple ourselves just to land
owned by ourselves you know it's all
areas people being at land don't buy out
so I know it refers to thirties and
suitable areas tree planting
so if 30s are not suitable
Thank You councillor missus ik first and
I think we've had enough questions on
this one I think the actual motion is
clear enough for what we need or now
take a vote on the motion as outlined by
councillor mrs. Macpherson and seconded
by Councillor mrs. Gooding those in
favor please please indicate any against
no abstentions that's been passed thank
you very much members right members will
take item 12 on the agenda this is the
coastal representation on the river
crouch coastal community team and this
will be presented by mrs. Hutchings
thank you chair members will remember in
July of this year that they resolved to
assume Secretariat role for the river
crouch coastal community team and to be
the accountable body for the funds grant
funding which came from central
government to that body the group has
met twice subsequently and renewed its
terms of reference which are attached to
the report the membership of the river
crouch coastal community team is
intended to be fluid and flexible and
there is no restraint on the numbers or
persons attending the work however off
the body is to be undertaken by the
steering group which will then
Commission projects to be undertaken
through discrete tasks and
groups the terms of reference
contemplates the election of a chair who
is a member of the Council given that as
I've mentioned the council is the
accountable body for the funding and
then with one other plus that person's
substitute to take a seat on that body
so in accordance with the recommendation
in the report it's it's proposed that
counselor mrs. Lumley be the chairperson
for the river crouch coastal community
team and that councillor
Simon wooden as portfolio holder for the
relevant subject area
together with our councilor Williams as
his substitute be the nominated to the
second post
Thank You Carol submission saw this
whole beach ball has one of the longest
boundaries on the crouch
why have you not considered someone from
the OB parish camp will not necessarily
need to be on the committee but do be
invited to go can you respond to that
if you look at page 12 and 19 the
representatives on the steering group
includes an elected councillor from
whole bridge parish council oh thank you
another any other questions members
council mr. hoy
rephrase the question I think given the
whole bridge has one of the longest
boundaries on the crouch why was not a
whole bridge District Council considered
for one of the positions Thank You mrs.
Hutchins the in I take the point in
relation to the the length of the river
and its adjacency to whole bridge the
position of this body however is that it
is a group set up to manage the
Secretariat and the funding and
therefore it's a project based group and
the you can see from the terms and the
aims and objectives of the group that is
intended not to be an emanation of the
council per se but it is a stake holding
group designed to work with business and
community leaders across the entire
length of the the crouch and its
estuaries including the the coast so on
that basis there was a discussion that
took place at a meeting of the the group
on 20th of November 2019 in those
conversations were had and the makeup
that you can see on pages 24 12 18 and
12 19 we're agreed out that Gruber
Stanley Thank You chairman give me will
the group be working with the
Environment Agency as it stands at the
moment as the if you like the cracked
wall is eroding away and they are
gradually replacing parts of it
and I do understand that there are parts
that are like parent owners do have we
contact do we and we contacted those are
are we working with those those people
thank you yes both those questions is
yes
the Environment Agency is intended to be
a member of the steering group and has
been attending previously in terms of
ownership of the lands we understand
that the many that are owned by
generational farmers and their families
so yes those are have been historically
involved with this group and will
continue to be so thank you no no that
none of the members indicating they wish
to speak I shall then therefore take a
vote on the recommendation as outlined
outlined on page twelve point two of the
report at paragraph 8.1 is had agreed
members agreed thank you
agenda item 13 members attendance at the
Royal garden party this will be
presented by Angela law Thank You
chairman members as you're aware the
council is usually invited to nominate
representatives to attend the Royal
garden party held at Buckingham Palace
each summer and invitations are extended
in recognition or past service in
previous years members have been
nominated attend the royal garden party
in strict Auto seniority based on the
total length of service and the centric
car and the civics chauffeur I have been
made available to transport them taking
this circ into account the members
eligible to attend next our councillors
counselor mr. Hawaii for ten years
service and counts mrs. Hawaii for nine
years service both members have
indicated they would not wish to take a
guess with them to the garden party
therefore a further representative plus
a guests of their choice can be
nominated this would be counselor mrs.
McPherson for eight year Service
Chairman the purposes reports to agree
they're tenants at the royal garden
party next summer for the any use of the
Civic car and civics over to transport
attendees as per the recommendation in
this report on page thirteen point two
paragraph seven thank you Thank You
councillor mr. Howe I think the report
reads or so I'm one of the people
attending or if I am attending it would
be at the I've not been told by my wife
whether or not she will be inviting me
as okay so I'm going to be attending so
in that capacity as attendees you might
well take somebody else so I'm sure she
would advise members obviously if that
thank you sorry there's no
counseling counselor mrs. hoi did you
wishes okay counselor mrs. Macpherson
Thank You members there is a
recommendation on page thirteen point
two with report at paragraph 7.1 is that
agreed Thank You members members that is
the last item the end